regardez comment antoine griezmann
annoncé l'arrivée de son enfant regarder
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup quand donc c'est un garçon
parce que les blancs sont bleus
évidemment c'est vrai que c'était sale
ont été imposées par gc viser une
lucarne on s'éclaire à la soie bleu donc
c'est un garçon et ce qui est encore
plus mignon vous c'est déjà ça c'est
mignon mais alors je sais pas si on a vu
un monsieur ou haï qui libère les
ballons c'est faire tisane allemands
alors que c'est quand même un champion
du monde il aurait pu faire un truc plus
learning ligne on a reproché aux
footballeurs d'être bling bling
là c'est fait à la maison et moi j'adore
moi j'aimerais la bible delphine scène
ça c'est vous trouvé ça mignon à mettray
comme nous vous l'annoncions premiers
mois justement alors là pour le coup je
sais pas je me projette pas mais moi je
suis daniel moi je trouve que c'est bien
justement que les footballeurs soient un
peu sont tout à fait des gens normaux et
puis on aime cette simplicité justement
je suis bien d'accord mais tu dis qu'on
a tapé sur eux et qu'on arrête de taper
aussi que les jeunes filles qui sortent
avec ceux entendus si tu sors avec un
footballeur déportés forcément idiote
havrais n'ont qu'à force et non il ya
des réseaux sociaux c'est bien on était
tous les réseaux sociaux vraiment de la
pâquerette il admire en valeur c'est une
belle utilisation des réseaux sociaux
qui sont décriés la bravo c'est bien